hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well so
faithfulness fidelity what do you mean
by that
ross talks about promises
and we recognize that when we make a
promise like when we say the words
i promise or we like sign our name
signature to something we're committing
ourselves
right and why do we feel like that that
creates an obligation well
that's part of what it means to
understand
promising according to to ross
here's where it gets really interesting
implicit promises
we make all sorts of explicit promises
don't we
um i'm going to show up at such and such
a time
we make a lot more implicit promises
and those are also
duties they they involve this sense of
being obligatory on us
so what would be examples of implicit
promises he gives you a few examples
here
an implicit understanding not to tell
lies
why i mean we could have some context in
which telling lies
is actually a good thing and as expected
couldn't we
like for example
this friend of mine who i saw at the
conference recently
told me that when he got to new york
city this is back in the 80s
that one of the things that everybody
was just doing in the part of the city
that he was living in was they would get
together
and they would just like bs each other
and each person would make up a
biography it was complete fabrication
you know like who they knew who they who
they worked with
what sort of thing they're into where
they're from
and everybody understood at the time
that it was
like a game you know and you try to
make up a better story than the person
before you
now imagine you're walking in off the
street
to to a bar where all these these people
are sitting around
coming up with these crazy stories you
would assume that they're true wouldn't
you
because we naturally assume that when
people are telling us things they're
actually giving us true information we
don't assume
people to be lying to us because there's
kind of an implicit promise in using
language
we can abrogate that in certain
situations but most of the time
we feel ourselves under an obligation to
to give correct information
what else would that include he says
writing books that purport to be history
and not fiction if you if you write a
book
and it's actually supposed to be history
book you're not supposed to make things
up
right you're supposed to actually have
some some
possible way of verifying the things
that you you're talking about
on the other hand if you're writing
fiction um
and you're actually saying that this is
not a true story
you probably shouldn't take an actual
true story
and represent it as being fiction right
then it's you know modeled after a true
story or something like that you put a
disclaimer in there
um so these are these are
duties of fidelity and he talks about a
few
more of these a little bit later he says
there's special obligations arising from
acts the very intention of which
when they were done was to put us under
an obligation that's
at the core of fidelity there's certain
acts by doing them
they put us under an obligation so what
would be examples of those
in our lives let's talk about the
classroom
you hand in a paper are there any duties
of fidelity sort of inherent
in the very act of handing in a paper
yeah um plagiarism like academic honesty
yeah you are you are you're presenting
as your own work
so now you can say well that's just a
kind of lying to plagiarize right but
it's also a kind of theft
and there's there's a different kind of
deception going on there now
sometimes professors make you actually
there's like a button you can click and
i learn
where the student has to acknowledge the
academic honor code and all that sort of
stuff
which is like 70 pages long at this
school you know i doubt anybody's
actually read through the entire thing
you're committed to it or think about
this
you've got you know smartphones and
other computer devices
where are you actually making agreements
all the time
software updates right you have to agree
to every time you have a new itunes
you have to click agree how many of you
actually read through
all that verbiage i don't myself
i probably should but i don't
there's actually a south park where
terrible things happen to one of the
characters because he didn't read the
stuff
i won't tell you what it is because
those of you don't watch south park
might be glorified
um what else what are other cases where
we
we create an obligation for ourselves by
by actually
choosing to take on an obligation
where you have a duty of fidelity what
about if you get married
that would be an example um
i mean at a very bare minimum what is
faithfulness in
marriage two hours or one in marriage
was it two yeah thanks uh
nobody's lying to me about that right
notice
duty of fidelity there um what is what
is the baseline for that consistent
don't screw anybody else just have sex
with your partner
that's that's pretty that's the bar is
pretty low there right
um what else might it include well think
about what wedding vows
often have in them iso and so it's where
to
do what clean up after you
cook your food not alienate
your mom and dad and brother and sister
it doesn't include stuff like that
it's a love right usually i hope
include that sort of thing love and
cherish
be true to one those are all obligations
that a person is taking
on to themselves in in doing that
if they don't want to you know feel
bound by them don't get married
right because that's that's what these
vows usually entail
what are other situations where you're
taking on an obligation
i took out an obligation when i agreed
to teach this class i'm going to
actually you know show up not just tell
personal anecdotes and
actually you know have some material for
you and
have you do something connected with the
material
you're supposed to learn something in
the class there's there's obligations
involved with that
do you have any obligations like that
you've taken on with your friends
are there implicit promises
and friendship what do you think
yeah that you'll be genuinely
okay that you won't conceal who you
are what you think
yeah i think that's right yeah it'd be
loyal he won't stab him in the back
yeah now you know often times when when
fights occur somebody said well i never
promised not to stab you in the back
right
but you could say look that's what it
means to be a friend when you became a
friend with me
if you're a ross you made an implicit
promise not to stab me in the back and
when the opportunity arose
uh you're not going to tell someone else
everything they're telling you
yeah that goes along with the honesty
part doesn't it you you confide in a
friend
then they're confiding in a friend they
actually i guess ross would say
produces a duty of fidelity
to not reveal that information to other
people
there's probably a lot of other duties
to not reveal that we could talk about
in that respect like you know doctor
patients
particularly for psychiatric things
counselors
any other ones lawyers have obligations
like that
there's certain professions that just by
entering into the profession you are
taking on a whole set of implicit
promises which you might you might break
right everybody else might break but
it's still recognizable as a breach
of fidelity
that is here's one other thing i want to
say about this
ross thinks that duties of fidelity are
what he's willing to call
perfect duties they have a high degree
of what he calls stringency
so they're not reducible to things like
it turns out better for everybody else
if you know
if you follow through on your duties
they're not reducible to anything else
other than the fact of having incurred
an obligation
and by virtue of having incurred an
obligation
this should take priority over other
things so for example
if the duty of fidelity were to come in
conflict with magnificence
like if by breaking my promise i could
make a number of other people
happy let's say for example that is very
far-fetched
i'm married right so i should be true to
my wife
we wanted to make this about um like you
know sexual change
there's what they call emotional affairs
right um
emotional affairs are where you there's
actually laws about this in the south
about estrangement of affection
have you ever heard this term it's an
interesting term means that if
i'm uh at least at a literal level if
i'm involved with you know
my wife she has a right to expect
affection from me and that my affection
is not going to somebody else instead
that other person who gets my affection
has estranged
my affection for my my wife like by
seducing me for example
so let's say instead there's no you know
hanky-panky
i decide i'm a good listener you know
and i can you know i could like get on
the internet
and maybe make a whole bunch of people
happy maybe
you know it's not even women women and
men all listen to their stuff
and what this very close emotional
connection
and um i wanted time for
my wife as a result but you know it's
i'm helping out like eight other people
i'm really improving their life
by doing so that's you know that's
meeting a duty of beneficence because
i'm improving
their condition not only saved just with
pleasure ross would say but
making them better people well i'm still
breaking implicit promise
to like not give other people a priority
over my spouse
and this has a greater weight this has a
greater stringency
ross would say there's a lot of cases
whereby
you know fudging our promises or
breaking them we could probably make a
lot of people happy
but we probably shouldn't do that as a
result
non-maleficence is a different kind of
story if by keeping my promise
i'm going to produce great harm to
another person i should break the
promise
so for example with with confiding in a
friend right
if you can find in in me that you
actually plan
to if you were a sniper where would you
go on the nearest
um that's probably the roof of the
hancock building right it'd be a good
location
that you were actually going to do that
and you know i know that you actually
have a rifle
and you've got like ammo out in the car
i know you're serious about this
you say look i don't want anyone else to
know but i really respect your
you know your your opinion and your
friendship and i just wanted to tell you
you know before i go i'm going to go
kill a whole bunch of people
i should tell somebody right i should
say oh well
dude a fidelity better not say anything
no non-maleficence trumps
fidelity in cases like that um if a
friend were to reveal
that they are engaging in you know very
risky or harmful behavior
maybe then i should i should also notify
somebody else
even though it breaks the
confidentiality
you know um are there cases where i
should lie
you know there there's the proverbial
case of the the
killer in the maternity ward you know
who wants to know where the babies are
so he can he can kill all of them
you tell them the opposite direction
right and you don't even need to really
think about it
and you don't say to yourself all right
you know i feel really conflicted
because i have this duty of fidelity not
to tell lies no in that case that's a
good thing to do
why well describe what you're actually
doing you are protecting it's not that
you're lying
so much it's that you're protecting
innocent lives
that's a better description of what
you're attempting to do isn't it
so duties of fidelity are going to be
pretty strong
in comparison to these other duties but
non-maleficence will use
usually trumpet
duties of reparation often arise when
you break a duty
of fidelity